okay so here we are eating your feet
it's a show where our best friend adam
challenges us to make ridiculous viral
foods from the internet we're going to
be making everybody's favorite category
of food it seems these days giant food
we have to make a really really big
burger here on tasty there's a show
called making it big our friend alvin
makes big things big burger big bun lots
of cheese that's upsetting okay making
the bun is definitely gonna be the
hardest part of this we have to make the
bun yeah we can't just find large buns
i'm excited about touching that soft
soft brioche dough that's a lot of
cheese
oh but he's making a slice of cheese oh
it's thick cheese i feel like you
shouldn't do this to cheese sauce some
burger sauce it looks like a cartoon it
does
very interesting it's a little upsetting
to be honest to turn this into an even
more ground-breaking burger ground
in fact yes ground beef breaking burger
we're going to be doing this with a meat
substitute
patty oh
yeah adam was pitching a bunch of
episode ideas for this season
and he said how about that giant burger
and i was like i'll do it if you replace
the meat with fake meat oh because i
didn't think he was gonna accept those
terms so this is your fault yeah earlier
you said that adam's our best friend but
he's my best friend he's a little bit of
a lie well you know who my best friend
is i have no it's not no is my best
friend
hi
are you on this fake meat train i've
never tried you can do it oh you think
we can yeah yeah do you think we can do
it and make it tasty
giant food that's worse
it's more like
quantities and quality right right we
can't have both yeah what if that's
gonna be my goal today i want to have
both okay it's gonna be my first no me
burger same yeah thanks good luck bye
it's time to make the burger bun
[Music]
we're working on our brioche dough but
the butter needs to be room
room temp and it just came out of the
fridge and it just came out of the
fridge so nikki's helping us out by
listen i walked into the room earlier
and andrew was shoving these into his
band's pockets i've heard chefs talk
about that we're using a brioche recipe
from
finecooking.com it makes small brioche
buns
but 16 of them we're each gonna make a
batch and then combine them because we
cannot double the recipe in one of these
mixers combine the flour
sugar yeast and salt
at a low speed until well combined so
we're going to continue mixing and add
four eggs and our milk should we crack
the eggs before we go can i just crack
them into my milk yes yeah why not let's
just do it
andrew
i learned a lot about why things don't
happen a certain way while baking cheers
okay so we're swapping from the paddle
to the hook
it's too big
oh
so my mixer is having a little bit of a
hard time with the size of the dough and
andrew and i have to combine our doughs
at some point so we might just
blob them in now we got a pretty big
mixer over here
look at this glass of water
it's like jurassic park in here
okay so now we're going to add our
butter
is it really soft enough it's having a
hard time
um i think it looks okay it's becoming
quite soft like a moose you feel good
about this
yeah you made brioche before yeah see
this was what i couldn't get right
because my butter to rest of the dough
ratio was far too high so it never came
together i don't think this is going to
pull off the sides it's just there's too
much of it you know adam just said if
our recipe is doubled would it taste
take twice as long to mix and quite
possibly yeah sounds terrible
it's starting to ball up at the top
[Applause]
oh you messed up this time
yeah it makes sense that that checks out
look at it look at it look at it look at
it oh
it like just became dough
it's a ball it's a smooth shiny ball
i think i'm too anxious to be a baker i
was ready to pull the plug on this thing
i know boy was i wrong
now does this look like what alvin did
in his video so satisfying oh
kind of yeah yeah
oh yeah oh that feels great right it's
like not that sticky i think we did i
think we did do it she's pretty i know
okay we're gonna cover it to let it rest
bye-bye
wow
our dough has nearly doubled wait watch
this
so we're gonna make a mold just like
alvin did for our baking sheet this is
huge
[Music]
is that enough i don't know
don't let it touch us real hard
could this wrap the both of us
yeah
is this sturdy enough i don't know i
don't think our dough is going to be big
enough to fill that up fill this his is
at least half of the size of ours is
right now
imagine the burger no but look at look
at our dough i want it no we're using
all of it yeah let's let's do it man big
is scary
[Music]
oh
so now we're going to punch down our
dough bowl oh it's so it's like leaking
put it in but just put it in just put it
in
okay so now we're just gonna let this
proof
oh it smells like bread
it smells like baked bread
that's comically large i think this is
ready to bake
this is gonna be an ugly bun
egg wash the top okay let's get a couple
eggs we are going to now put this into
our preheated oven
okay so while the
bun is in the oven we're going to prep
some of our vegetables you wanted
caramelized onions so i'm going to slice
them up throw them in this pan right
here you're going to work on sliced
sliced tomatoes let's go check that
brioche i think we need to cover the top
because it's very brown
and it's only going to get browner
oh
nikes
we should uh but how
it means
i need a foil hat
i'm a baker you know a good burger sauce
really can make or break a burger this
is gonna upset some people mayonnaise is
very polarizing this whole video is
gonna upset some people we want a nice
orangey color yeah yeah oh you're gonna
add the relish yeah but more ketchup
first should we put a little relish in
yes i know you're so excited about the
relic well you don't like pickles but
don't like pickles i will accept a
little relish in the sauce this is gonna
i think add okay good
stop there let's give it a taste oh
no why didn't you eat that like a
mouthful of soup it could use more
relish for sure no we caramelized the
onions for you
no what are you doing
what's wrong with one of you now we're
making a burger
okay so it's time to assemble our patty
we're going to smash
them onto this baking sheet just like
alvin does in his video did you want to
get some spices did you want to get some
spices i'm going to start plopping them
out onto the sheet so it actually kind
of smells like ground beef a little it's
like fainter the smell
so this is like my standard burger size
probably
all right we gotta check that bun i'm
getting nervous now wow
yeah we're good
cool so we just need to make a patty
that's this big
two patties that big also meat shrinks
when you cook it for sure start with
some salt i also got roast smoked
paprika and regular paprika because i
feel like you would have an opinion i
don't but both sound lovely okay uh some
black pepper sure garlic powder
it's very cold
throw them in throw them in see what
happens i turned it up to 475.
so alvin made a
giant version of a slice of cheese
right he like melted it and then re
congealed it do you want to do that or
do you want to just not purchase
[Music]
we're back from the store with our main
objective the cheese
our main cheese thankfully they let us
buy this
thankfully they let us
okay we've got our
glorious block of american cheese the
finest cheese perhaps for
burgers why is this knife sticky i use
it to cut the onions
so adam's thinks that we should do it
the long way i agree with adam but that
looks like a difficult task
okay yeah that's going to be tough yes
i'm just going to tell you right now no
matter how hard i'm going to try it's
probably going to be a little crooked
and everyone's going to have to be fine
with that okay
should we steal a little bit yeah
kitchen mice
oh yeah this is nice you made a good
bath bread this one should not be a
burger bun no
this is a straight-up cake
this is just oh
yeah
that's enough cheese we're gonna go put
this on the patties
look at all that oil
oh
uh i mean it's not exciting looking
does it have to be exciting looking
did we like maybe like overcook it
upsetting some cheese on yeah
nice even distribution
i don't want anyone to see me like this
you know
like i'm upset by a lot of this oh you
got to get way more cheese than that
don't leave me alone
so we think our brioche is a little too
fragile to be toasted so we're going to
also it's so delicious
we're going to skip toasting let's sauce
the bottom it's going to be a light
saucing this is silly though
what's silly all of this all of the
above everything we've done today yeah
everything is silly it has a very
suctiony effect like i wish i didn't
know this wasn't meat
all right i'm going for it it feels like
it's ready to go
[Music]
it's too
big it doesn't shrink up like
regular cut it all the way away next one
yep here it comes
[Music]
there's cheese squirting out the front
right now we just keep going yeah onions
yeah onions plop them on
i hate those
this top patty is sliding off the bottom
patty
shove it back on hold it hold it in
place
[Music]
[Applause]
too far it's gonna have to be it needs
to balance itself out yeah go lettuce
no there's no time keep moving
good stop putting lettuce on there
andrew stop it looks really horrific i'm
gonna start smearing sauce on the top
bun okay all right i think this burger
looks the way that i feel on the inside
about this marker
okay should we put its hat on
it's going to have to fall to a certain
degree i can help that problem
[Music]
you i don't know guys i think it looks
pretty good
i'm not mad at this this is this is
instagram versus reality right here okay
that's gonna be this i'm okay with this
like it barely looks like a food
can't wait for really to see this she's
gonna never be friends with any of us
ever again she's not coming back she's
gonna quit for sure
approach very slowly
come closer to me
but look away okay okay and
can i watch yeah
[Music]
is it bigger
i don't know
look at this oh bad
aren't you always the one who's like you
eat with your eyes
but it's like are your eyes eating now i
mean like giant burger this is giant
burger if you made too small i would be
disappointed but this is giant burger
okay so if your expectations were just
lost yeah i wasn't expecting like
gourmet what would are we going to do
just because it smells like a burger
it's crazy it's burger
are you gonna eat it yeah okay
[Music]
all i got was a lettuce
lego meat how's the meat
really yeah i think it's fake meat
it's actually not bad here we come
[Music]
boom
holy crap
oh my god oh look cheese full look at
those
when we put the top on top everyone in
this room started crying
that looks incredible though right yeah
listen it smelled real weird while we
were cooking it is it good oh yeah
really all right i'm gonna get a slice
okay so jay's crying because she can't
believe how good it is
and i can't either but i think this
maybe proves the idea that a sloppier
burger is a better burger so it doesn't
quite look as clean as alvin's but i'm
actually shocked how good it tastes it
tastes like an actual burger
i don't know
look it's been a rollercoaster of
emotion today adam is shaking the camera
because he's laughing
ready three two one
hold your hands like this
right i don't know
[Music]
i said at the start of this i hated that
adam was making me do this challenge but
now i'm kind of uh no i still please
[Music]